so what would happen if you consumed
just two tablespoons of extra virgin
olive oil every single day that's a
topic for today there's a lot of amazing
things in olive oil that people have no
clue and there's a couple ways you can
take it I put it on my salad and this is
my I don't know if you can see this
right here this is my olive oil right
here okay I use a very specific type
because it's the real stuff I've been to
the farm in Italy where they grow these
olives it's called vittori San Michele
atori okay but anyway unfortunately a
lot of the olive oil out there is fake
and I had no idea of fake versus real
for many many years and probably until
five years ago when I actually tasted
real extra virgin olive oil and I'm like
wow this is amazing before I was
consuming this fake olive oil that was
Bland it didn't really have any taste
didn't have that uh peppery grass like
taste and it didn't irritate the back of
my throat those are just indicators you
have the real thing because
Unfortunately they sometimes dilute
olive oil with other oils like soy or
Canola so they're trying to clean that
up right now but it was quite amazing
when I went to this Farm where they
created solid oil I had a chance to
check the soil and check the microbes
which are off the chart also the care
involved in making this product was just
way over the top I mean this goes Way
Beyond just organic now I don't get any
kickbacks from this company but I will
say when I find a good product I
definitely will let people know about it
so you can either add it to your salad
with balsamic vinaigrette or apple cider
vinegar I put some lemon on my salad I
put sea salt or you can just take two
tablespoons of this oil every day it's a
pure fat so it's not going to spike
insulin so let me just go through some
of the compound pounds in olive oil okay
and I'm not going to give you the long
names because every time I do that I
tend to put people to sleep so I'll just
bring it up on the slide and I'll go
through the different effects that can
be created so this first phytonutrient
has some pretty powerful cardio
protective properties okay
giving you significant blood pressure
lowering effects you have two different
types of blood pressure you have primary
and secondary
another name for primary is called
essential so essential hypertension and
what's interesting about that is that it
doesn't have a cause they don't know
what the cause is and that's 95 of all
the blood pressure problems out there
they don't know what the cause is of
course we have all sorts of medications
to help you in the meantime until we
find a cause and since we're on the
topic of this you might also want to add
vitamin D and more potassium as well as
lowering your sugar because when you
have insulin resistance you can make the
arteries really really hardened and your
blood pressure will go up but the point
is that extra virgin olive oil can help
you they even make the special point if
you're on medication and you're taking
olive oil at the same time your blood
pressure could come down too low I mean
why wouldn't you want something without
side effects to lower your blood
pressure I mean the solution is just to
take less medication right some other
benefits include anti-cancer it also
protects the hypothalamus and another
part of your brain called the substantia
nagra which has everything to do about
dopamine and if you have a problem with
that part of your brain you can end up
with Parkinson's so olive oil protects
the brain and has neural protective
properties and another really important
thing about olive oil is it's very
anti-inflammatory there's a lot of
things in extra virgin olive oil that
help with inflammation and pain so let's
move on to the next phytonutrient this
one again gives you anti-inflammatory
benefits it can act as an analgesic to
help with pain it has antimicrobial
effects and also it can help support the
beta cell the pancreas which has
everything to do with helping your blood
sugars and also with helping lowering
insulin
because the beta cell makes insulin all
right in this next compound there's
anti-cancer properties as well as
anti-arthritic benefits and then in
these last three phytonutrients which
are sterols a sterile is a compound
that's very similar to cholesterol and
also similar to steroids and so in this
first compound there's benefits with uh
benign prostatic hypertrophy if you get
this enlarged prostate extra virgin
olive oil can help you this
phytonutrient also helps you balance
cholesterol specifically LDL and I'm
talking about the small dense particles
okay and then we get another
phytonutrient which is a another sterol
which is anti-inflammatory and also what
can benefit your LDL and then there's
another sterol which can also help with
your LDL so there are a lot of different
phytonutrients I just covered only six
of them but there are hundreds of
naturally occurring compounds with all
sorts of very cool effects there's also
by the way a good amount of vitamin E in
extra virgin olive oil so I hope in this
video I convinced you to start using
more olive oil on a regular basis it can
really help you and if you haven't seen
this video on olive oil you definitely
want to check it out I put it up right
here